Let's move up a dimension into
a three dimensional space and
let's start out by
thinking about planes.
We're going to start by studying
planes in three dimensional space
because they are highly analogous
to lines in two dimensional space.
Just like a single linear
equation Ax + By = k in codes
aligned in two dimensional space
A single linear equation Ax
+ By + Cz = K encodes a plane
in three-dimensional space.
Another way to view the equation
Ax + By + Cz equals k
is like before,
a dot product of two vectors, A B C.
x y z = k.
And like before with lines.
If we take A, B, C dot x, y, z = 0.
That means that vectors from
the origin to points x, y,
z in the plane are orthogonal
to the vector A, B, C.
Thus A, B,
C is a normal vector to the plane.
And also like with lines changing
the value of the constant term k
shifts the plane but it doesn't change
the direction of the plane at all.
So regardless of the constant
term the plane defined
by Ax + By + Cz = k has
ABC as a normal vector.
Let's call two planes with
parallel normal vectors parallel,
since their faces are in
the same direction.
If we have two parallel planes Ax +
By + Cz = k1 and Ax + By + Cz = k,
the same coefficients in
front of each variable but
different constant terms And
that means any point XYZ satisfying
the first equation can't satisfy
the second and vice versa.
So two different parallel
planes do not intersect.
This is just like the case
with lines in two dimensions,
two different lines with the same
normal vector don't intersect.
We also have another analogy to our
treatment of lines in two dimensions.
Remember that if we knew two lines were
parallel then we could check to see if
they were the same line by finding the
vector between a point on one line and
a point on the other.
If that vector was orthogonal to
each of the lines normal vectors
then the lines are the same.
Similarly if two planes are parallel
that is they have parallel normal
vectors then we can pick a point on one
plane and another point on the other.
If the vector connecting them is
orthogonal to the planes normal vectors
then the two planes must be the same.